hey everybody welcome to a very special
episode of top 5 scary mode to the week
I am cam Robinson we have said Ford here
hello who's this jerk
oh it's Marc what oh yes it is and I am
the Vegas show this is uh this is your
Skyrim mods debut you've never been on I
don't never know I've never even bought
it a Skyrim before no even like we
didn't even put you know I don't even
like I know this is a bad that's a bad
thing to admit on the Skyrim oh yeah
yeah all right well your first and only
approach would you say though can I say
I admire Skyrim you can and its fans and
it's mana fans many handsome fair yes I
yeah okay good what are we doing today
it's speaking of handsome what are we
doing we're building building this right
this now I'm no expert but this is just
a case currently it's not a PC case when
we're building you guys wanted a new
awesome PC to play Skyrim mods we did
that was actually exactly what we are
and as one of game sports premier game
tech people this guy um I've hooked you
up with a bunch of stuff thank you thank
you have cool stuff what does it do what
does it all do it will play PC games in
particularly Skyrim one of super uber
awesome sayings with all the mods you
can throw on so we can stop lying about
the fact that we've been running it on
low or not honestly we've not be running
about VGA like right so yeah we've got
loads of cool stuff we've got this bit
finished case we got some BitFenix fans
we've got this cool corsair ram 16 at
gigs were seas around yeah so the plan
is because we want to do an episode
where we use this pc rebuilding now yeah
to like put on all the graphics mods all
the EMDs but we need one but you know
get skyrim looking we're gonna make the
deuce muscle like we've got sexy Skyrim
project yes well working tonight
this thing is gonna do that we have this
which is a brand new SSD this is
SanDisk's brand new what's it called
extreme streaming pro oh good
right just regular pros rub screen froze
this is 480 gigs it's also got 550 Meg
read speed which is redonkulous I we
have also got the AMD FX
kro ATX form factor which is where the
AMD eight core yes they are not as fast
as intel like a straight speed but you
know it's a really good gaming pc
processor okay really you're getting pc
process and it take you away this is an
asus motherboard because this is the
only motherboard that is good at four
micro ATX with a yeah basically no
choice just get this this one literally
this one won't tell you what it is you
just got to read the box
Oh read the box because motherboard have
stupid names like hi my name is opposed
to know me hey hi second 85 shut up with
three about the m5 a7 al BAM yeah I did
well seriously whoever comes up with it
I I actually thought I was trending yeah
okay that was definitely we've also got
this is uh this is a Corsair h75 which
will help with your water cut out your
overclocking because it's a water
coolers and all-in-one okay keeping it
simple for you guys that's a power
supply these 150 it's a 750 s another
course that one because Corsair make the
best power supplies horse there make the
best powers but is not a lie they really
do um and when we get that massive check
where we gonna be a horse air from the
course as a no reason also stuff because
genuinely they make the best gaming room
they're all in one water coolers are
excellent but they're PS use as well
pretty much the best you yet and they're
small enough to fit in this yes this one
is what about you 750 watts that
standard size so it good and then we got
some other accessories we've got a cool
course a mess we got some some BitFenix
headphones we've got a bunch of stuff
over there me oh this this was there's
an empty box this is an empty box but
this is the arctic cooler extreme for
and the reason for this is because of
this bad boy
so this is AMD's r9 290x which is
basically the most expensive no not this
is second second most expensive great
you've got a silver medal yeah
everything because this when when I got
this this was the best they made and
then they brought out the are nine to
five to nine 5 X 2 X 2 X 2 whatever why
we've got this separate cooler ons
because the one we got came with this
cooler yeah okay and this is the stock
cooler for this sort
the disinfecting the one reference
design it's kind of like I seen it I'm
no expert but I can see one fan I think
so yes three fan yes yeah that means
this is an got more fan and cooling on
both sides on that one now really yeah
yeah so I mean that that the reference
call it basically is really crappy at
keeping these very very hot running
cards cool yeah so it specially small
keys yeah especially in a small case and
when you use the stock version of this
card it actually tends to clock itself
down stay cool so you don't get full so
it will win its wins this sucker on
which I've it is freakin ginormous it
just fits in there just fit yeah um it
basically will stay very very cool I've
tried it it's great
it's actually really quiet as well
really all we got to do is build the
Eneco together all right he'll be uh
watch all right you know watch as long
as the thing play Skyrim at the end I
have never built a PC in my life really
never am I ever in my life okay it's my
first ever PC build right this is gonna
be in light Andy for you though yeah i
dispatched to come away from this a
complete expert you will be able to be
expert okay okay feel the keyboard as
well look at that that is an amazing boy
holy [ __ ] Corsair
I just found a Corsair tube it's the
biggest mouse makes it uh is a long
what's the idea raised is that you put
your keyboard on it and your mouse on
the side you put everything on it it's
like goes across you down leave it is -
I'll take this guy don't worry guys I
got it oh I just did he go I just did a
thing I didn't want you to do that I
didn't think but you really didn't want
you to stick that thing down long it
took me to put those back here what's
the order of thing depending on the cage
it depends on the case this feels like a
tech version of Saturday kitchen it does
yeah I like side occasion like screw
management make sure that you're like
keeping them in a good place you know
where they go yeah and we just sort of
like economy some screw management here
you lads do anything right why do you
need this it comes loose anti-static oh
yes who it is you lay on top they were
crispy declare so what we've got here is
the CPU and when you build
so basically when you've got your board
yep um Intel AMD doesn't matter
maybe I want to do is get your chip on
there basically okay um I'd like to
think this is the very safe part of the
process right this is a big I can't
screw up this is the bin anyway shape of
a bit that you can really screw up is
much worse with Intel processors the
reason is because the pins are actually
on the board not the CPU okay I know
we're really there is break the pin on
God so you just got annoyed with this so
even he's a good like punching technique
I'm all right that's right punch it
punch it in there yes it's a little
easier because the Pens are sturdy are
on this yeah there's a corner on each
one which is highlighted and then you
know which won't go yeah look at that
that's a corner that's highlighted more
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna stand back
I want no responsibility for when this
goes wrong it's it done right it sounds
a no yeah yeah so that's done right yes
we beat her up yeah yeah it's very much
Skyrim pre-installed on that brings sort
on the CPU it is such a good game
everyone okay so now we've done that the
next thing to do is to get our CPU
cooler CPU cooler not the RAM not the
RAM and it's by brand but if you heard
of them but it's it's coarser oh no way
cool yeah yeah if you never built PC
before don't worry cuz I'm gonna try and
be the questions that you would ask as a
situational I mean so I can ask young
questions here's a pro tip for you a
private tip when you get fans for
radiators they usually have a high
pressure rating and the higher the
pressure rating the better for a
radiator however the lower pressure ones
are generally better for other areas of
the case so and this actually comes
pre-installed with like thermal grease
okay okay that all right that's off all
right pearl I'm gonna see more replacing
it with that one no this is the killer
I'm building a PC yep
they said it couldn't be done we're
gonna attach this to the figure out how
this is gonna the layout of it okay it's
gonna be in there we just it is gonna be
in there case is in here right right
action here reads the squeeze against a
she's gonna radiators go back back man
that's so cold high school
sexy refrigerator and this this is
liquid-filled right we're gonna fill
this radiator with with goo that's
prefilled we don't believe anything like
zero is zero maintenance a form of
liquid form of a great liquid of some
form so I'm here you on the board
basically there are holes I mean you
need to make sure that there are
standoffs where each those holes are one
there okay another one they one up here
yeah yeah in line with this that one
there's one above it so what's a gap
hold on give it this sorry shocker
this is scientific okay there yeah it's
the top one excellent so now we need to
get this from here somehow and Oh God
also being a complete nightmare on the
other one so I'm gonna just stand back
doing a hell he'll make guys do that cuz
that look that worried on earth is the
point okay there we go that was easy as
easy what's fine
I think glad that went straight in there
protip late April spray-painting the
motherboard go pay through the roof for
red colored motherboards spray paint man
with household you tired that's going
through I feel like that's not a protip
yeah
as a captain no lie yep which screw
allows me anti-aliasing is it that one
no the anti-aliasing screw will attach
later and see it's it's here cuz it's
got the jagged edges you see it you got
you
that's the anti-aliasing screwed
actually there's an ambient occlusion
screw somewhere put little shadows now
we need to figure out now we've done
this
yeah then we to figure out what fans
we're gonna use and what red ones
what on air flow with in this case
you're going to lots of air flow it's an
obnoxiously baby you spin it for the
camera squiggle spin look at that now we
breaking it now way in a minute wait a
minute
we put that in there no KS use on your
visit who designed this case may I think
we can put that here yeah yeah yeah cool
I was gonna suggest but in the 200 mil
their weight means that we use there's
nothing wrong I sort of think that yeah
be a shame not to use the 200 mil
frankly alright alright
yeah sorry this is the 200 mil although
if it like yeah if it lights up and it's
on the bottom that's not much good for
us right
have we meant to see the lights you'll
see it'll be like one of those cars I
was gonna say if we didn't use this I
could maybe mount it on top of my
monitor and it could give me a cool
breeze while I work
yep okay so bathes you and beautiful red
light so far this has been the easiest
Skyrim mods ever I know we've had a
single mod fail no nothing's crashed no
hope take this guy back up again
what are these screws made of like paper
or something they thread so quickly um
Campari does grow so everything else
underneath it's not still gonna fit ro
I'm saying that's why we're perfect
screwed yeah where this additional fans
I'm gonna check where we go gosh that
breaking crunching sound means it's this
like basically if you're using the stock
cooler which we didn't want to do you
wouldn't have this problem we definitely
can't put the fans on the top no they
won't fit that's like too shallow like
you can see like that's the fitness
figure out where you want your kept how
you're gonna run your cables I get in
this case it's probably better that
they're on that side too they're near
the board and we can hide them again
would recommend rubber grommets if you
can okay just it's only for these guys
so cuz again they're gonna shake a bit
the fan controller no longer she fit
she's just like stick it to the front
and glue or something let's have a look
let's have a look what's more important
cooling or bitchin as graphics card no
no so there's no no physical way for
this to fit you get the mad power is you
have to sacrifice looks for raw power
that's what captain hey shut up set your
new graphics card
it's an AMD in video hybrid oh my god
what this is the GeForce GTX 780 which
is a very very nice graphics card as you
can see it is much much equal really
working on 680
in the current you're rockin a 680 this
is like is there he'll give you big
boost
why are we making in such a small case
when we could be making it in a new
position normal case it's the challenge
fan control is in all right let's get
rid of our sad but very powerful graphic
our chip so we're doing okay we're gonna
like lose a little bit
they're floating is going to destruct it
but there's nothing we can do about that
our power cables are in for our PSU all
that's left really is to oops
plug in you extra bits and pieces so now
we need to figure out which fans you
want to be for which things let's just
see on here so with RAM slots this is
got four they usually color-coded so you
know which ones are one two three and
four and obviously jewel channel Ram say
obviously this is dual channel RAM and
the ballsiest your channel Ram so you
want to install them in pairs ideally
you can install one and you won't get
too much performance hit but we're using
two eight gigs so you have 16 gigs in
RAM where do we put the hard drives the
hard drive yes in this go on a side
mounted racket take our temperature
sensors no either side where we put
these because your CPU temperature we
wanted in software and see it when you
come in really what we're going to use
these for is ambient temperature in the
case so I'm plugging in this USB header
so you've got your front USB port sorted
okay we've also got here so these are
going to be your power LEDs which is
blah blah we don't believe that one
second audio audio well that's weird how
does that work how did we get this off I
don't tell me it's like that because I
will cry hello don't know you're right
it goes this way this is right this is
right I'm thinking this yeah it's better
so you guys ran that way laughs it's not
going in the video can you please just
cut it now where I just say well that is
not going in the video potentially I
mean maybe it goes in those little
grooves on the side yes yes okay now you
can either put like yeah keep them both
at the top they'll have keep the cables
and idea mm-hmm come on cam but stick
with it and dig them mmm yes yes why
okay then yeah it's in why okay we're
nearly done oh crap okay so we got two
you're on trying
great the owner just stick the
temperature gauge on the bottom half the
graphics card right yeah well sticker so
yeah in a big dope
what are you playing exactly he's plying
the SATA cables into their SATA ports
right oh come on whoops
and cam drops another thing yeah drop in
because I keep playing with paying that
then goes out and don't try to be
patient so flavor stuff days I just got
a shoe golubev it sugar lit about you go
above it okay I actually said shuffle I
said jiggler see droid the Scottish more
abrasive term for shuffling it's also a
dance style like no no it's not you
would shuffle in advance you wouldn't
choose that like you don't have that
song every way I'm jiggling or hand
cramp which is hey yeah yeah shilling
that's a great stuff every day of
Sugarland oh my skin can use everyone
for weeks in you to hold this I can't be
English leaning on the pins I gotta go
you got a pal yeah oh man it get old
serve you give you a tired weary fingers
arrests so we've got a power supply in
our front mounted fan unit all our fans
are in we've got our CPU cooler yeah a
ram plus our graphics card which is a
GTX 780 the cable tidying yet isn't
great I'm gonna lie about that there is
not a lot of room to like there's no
room in this case two high cables
basically so like with other cases you
would stick them behind the motherboard
have a really nice clean look we could
probably do a little better we're
talking some of these URLs but honestly
it's real difficult in this case it's
not too bad it shouldn't have struck too
much air flow because there's not a lot
coming in from the front
there's no front intake apart from the
PSU so we should be good so we got do is
make our hard drives plug it all in turn
it on yeah boom
taken taken commander screwdriver you
ever do I'm giving the screws okay
yep he's screwed a lot if we hold to a
screw that
well you find some screws on this
alright well type of screws big thread
style yeah
Big Willie star singular style what an
hour and that was a oh this is just the
front of the cases and that's that's the
case lighting and I know it goes all the
way long
Oh what case lighting yeah is kind of
the other end okay this case because it
is likes easily obnoxious like you
what are you saying about our show yeah
we think it makes sense
so it's magnetized just magnetized huh
put the top on okay which way does it go
this way you know yeah does that just
like just sit on top of that just
doesn't have like a thing that it sits
in doesn't matter too late its press the
button it's working we're done oh look
at the front oh yeah okay so I don't
know if it's arrowed because it doesn't
have an internal speaker but what we do
know about it is that the red is glowing
yeah going right on top it's growing
it's quite cool hello Aang red on the
bottom little can't release that's
definitely blowing air so wick was
wondering what the green is it's the GTX
yeah Vidia green in there so this is a
nice RM new problem wonderful well it
really no PC that can play a four year
old a three year old game actually and
also muddied up the buzzy cuz I animals
usually go pretty good work mark I guess
yeah ii so ah but we got there yeah i
mean we basically carried you through it
yeah i think we're responsible for the
fact that it's even on at all so the
grid question is how many exploding
chickens can this thing handle I can't
wait to find out actually I'm expecting
I hope we can push past a 200 mark 200
mark would be nice
Trek we could get full four figures it
depends what otherwise were okay I'm
running but alright start I want to try
a full figure chicken explains how we're
gonna benchmark this yes computer okay
well I guess that is it days week we
have the PC it's built it's on it was a
piece of cake that we did in one single
sitting
definitely definitely what does that
mean no or a day or day Ellie done but
next week is when we're next week it's
going on this the only the governs needs
go on and we're gonna use this to make
the
best-looking scarran we're going to try
and make it look as photorealistic as
possible now we we do have a different
graphics car but according to Mark
Walton that shouldn't make too much of a
difference right not too much difference
too much but only a little tiny tiny all
right so it's gonna not be quite
photorealistic it is and that's gonna be
our excuse doesn't look good nerf rectly
what you can see only we had that
graphics card that was the size of a
human torso I think we should hit the
pub and leave marks tidy all this up
that's great okay cool well guys thanks
for watching hope you enjoyed watching
mark and me probably make it worse and
save help quite long you should ask you
could tweet him how he did in his yeah
builds mark what's your Twitter handle
there's a at mark
Alex multiple nice suite you can rape me
for dropping things that can for us Rob
and you can congratulate me on being
spectacular building pcs out ready said
we go for being modest alright guys
thanks we'll see you next week for more
top 5 scary modes of the week